all right good morning everyone welcome
to our last lecture so today I don't
have any new course content to share my
plan for today is to make a few
announcements talk a little bit about
grading and maybe some big-picture stuff
and then open the floor to questions
from you so some people have already
been asking questions on chat about
course content that I'm going to try to
address today please post your questions
in chat and I'll try to answer them and
I'm happy to answer questions for exam
review so our exam is next Tuesday our
found our final exam is next Tuesday
I'll talk a little bit about a little
bit more about the fat and the format of
that in a second but you probably
already saw if you're in the class you
saw that I posted a huge document of
practice questions for the exam so my
suggested technique for studying for the
exam which I mentioned before but I'll
mention again is to just start going
through this document talk over the
questions with your friends and anything
that you're stumped on you can ask us
the course stuff on on slack or if you
have questions that you're already
confused about you can ask right now in
this lecture so so let's let's get
started um so what do I want to say to
you today well first of all one thing
that I want to say is that I'm proud of
you this this quarter has been tough
this year's been tough
what have we had to deal with this
quarter at UCSC well this was my second
year second year is supposed to be
easier than the first but let's see we
had lots of lots of Public Safety power
shut offs there were strikes the grad
students went on strike there were other
strikes as well most visibly the grad
students went on strikes I went on
strike I support the grad student strike
by the way I'm happy to talk to people
about that
and but that's a topic for another time
obviously the global pandemic and then
the last few days we've been in the
middle of the nationwide epidemic of
police brutality and so this this year
has been this year's been rough and
especially for those of you who are
seniors which is the majority of the
class you don't even get a graduation
ceremony not a real one so it's kind of
unfortunate right your your your your
college experience does not get to end
in the way that you would surely hoped
it would so I'm very proud of you all
for your incredible resilience in the
face of everything that you've had to
deal with and it's clear that a lot of
you have learned a lot in this class
despite the circumstances so I've been
very impressed by the questions that
some of you who have been asking in the
comments that some of you have have been
sharing and and I hope that you got as
much out of this class that I have
gotten out of teaching it so so the the
first thing I guess that I want to say
is that I'm proud of you on that note um
course evaluations sets are happening so
do them please this is a this is
something that I've been I've so I've
been here for two years as I mentioned
and every quarter the response rate for
sets gets lower so it was it was pretty
good my first quarter here of fall 18
and then every quarter it's gotten a
little bit lower and you know I can I
can try to you know wheedle you up you
and and no jutsu complete them and even
like dangle a carrot like last quarter I
told the students that I would make
balloon animals
in class if a certain number if a
certain percentage of the class filled
out sets I'm really bad at making
balloon animals so it would have been
hilarious but you know I don't so why
should why should you actually do this
like why am i netting you so hard to do
this well it actually matters in terms
of reappointment and promotion and
tenure time so that I've even even in
the short time that I've been here I've
been able to participate in the process
for a few promotion cases and it's
always the the it's always the case that
what people write on sets is relevant so
this is one of the few times I don't
know if you know what happens with with
your course evaluations with your sets
when you fill them out but not only do I
read them and they're completely
anonymous by the way but not only do I
read them but my department chair in my
department gets access to them as well
and they're used in decisions about how
should courses be adjusted who should
teach what and so on and and furthermore
okay I mean we can admit that some
professors you know especially
professors who've been teaching for
decades their teaching style is pretty
awesome I'd and they're probably not
going to change how they teach but I am
still capable of changing right so if
you if there are ways in which I can
change to make the course better I want
to know what they are and if there are
things that I've done that you like and
that you want to encourage you should
say so so this is really important to us
so please please don't continue the
downward trend try to try to reverse the
trend so uh it's it's it's down it's
really invisible guys it's like it's
something like twenty percent response
rate now try to do better than that I
would be awesome if we could get it like
a twenty five or thirty percent response
rate at least for these I know it's it's
not exactly your top priority right now
but if you can take ten or fifteen
minutes to do it you don't even have to
answer every question
but even if you can take 10 or 15
minutes to do it and and and and just
even give a cursory answer to some of
the questions that that would be
creating alright enough about that um
grading so let's talk a little bit about
grading so um all of you have seen this
before but I'll share the grading scale
for the for the course just as a
reminder so so here's the official
grading scale so the in-class quizzes
that we've done almost every day are
worth 10 percent of your grade and those
aren't created on content by the way
they're only graded on if you fill them
out so if you if you literally wrote
poop on every single in-class quiz you
would still get credit for it the
midterm was worth 20% final 24% the
project 46% so let me let me talk about
this for a second so so first of all
this this 10% for the quizzes um we're
being very lenient with this so we did
21 quizzes the first one everyone gets
credit for cuz the first one I forgot to
even collect email addresses but so
there's 21 quizzes we're gonna say
everybody gets a few for free so if you
if you filled out 21 quizzes or 20
quizzes or 19 quizzes you get full
credit
after that you lose a couple of points
per quiz that you missed so this means
that something like 70% of the class
gets full credit for these in-class
quizzes which I'm perfectly fine with um
so those should be easy points um we
have this policy that if your final exam
score is higher than your midterm score
then the final score will replace the
midterm so for those of you who really
on the midterm for whatever reason your
final exam is an opportunity to redeem
yourself so in other words so if the if
this is the grading scale now this what
I'm showing right here let's switch back
to paper so
so so if this is what it is we will say
that if you got if you did better on the
final if you do better on the final than
you did on the midterm then then the
grading scale so this is like option a
option B is this and we will pick
whichever one of those options you do
better with now some people have asked
if we can actually de-emphasize the
final rather than emphasize it and so
I'm sympathetic to that especially given
how difficult everything has been in the
last couple of weeks so we're gonna add
a third option so the third option looks
like this
so it's 20% each for the exams and 50%
for the project so what we'll do is
we're going to calculate your grade each
of these ways and then give you the max
so this third option is intended to help
people who are doing well on the project
but who for whatever reason struggle on
exams we don't want to get rid of the of
the exam component altogether and that's
because there's very little opportunity
in this course to to really evaluate
your individual performance so the the
project evaluates how you do in a group
but a lot of people struggle with that
for whatever reason maybe they ended up
in a bad group no so so so we need a way
to evaluate your individual performance
and the exams are kind of the only
option to do that um so so these are
these are the choices we're gonna we're
going to compute your grade in all of
these ways and then give you the best so
you don't have to pick one
we'll just automatically pick out
whichever one is most beneficial for you
um alright that's that's about all I
have to say about creating in terms of
so somebody has to how about an option
to de-emphasize the project so the main
thing that I have to say about that is
this um if you if you are really
struggling on the project you can ask
for the option of getting it incomplete
in the class so you can't take an
incomplete so there's no way to make up
the final later right so the final is
the final you
can't do it later but it is possible to
take more time to do the project by
asking for an incomplete let me warn you
so some students took an incomplete in
the class that I taught last quarter
incomplete means that you cut you work
with the professor to come up with a
schedule to do the work but it has to be
done within a quarter and if you don't
do it within a quarter your grade
automatically turns into an F so that
works well for some people who are very
disciplined and are able to kind of get
the project done despite the fact that
they have other stuff going on but it
but really like you you probably want to
be done with this chapter of your life
right you probably just want to be done
so you can talk to me about that option
if you want to but I wouldn't recommend
it unless you're extremely
self-motivated okay so um that's it for
logistical stuff that I want to talk
about right now let's talk a little bit
about about distributed systems so like
I said we're not going to cover any new
content today but we are gonna answer
questions that people ask so so one
question was so I one of the questions
on the the review document I shared was
or the practice questions document um
had to do with with the this idea of
making copies for fault tolerance so the
question was what are two or three ways
in which making copies aids with fault
tolerance so the first thing we have to
ask ourselves is okay fault tolerance
like what kinds of faults are we talking
about so we talked about several kinds
of faults right we talked about crash
faults we talked about omission faults I
talked about Byzantine faults
Krosh felts and omission falter that are
the ones that we're focusing on most in
this course okay so how does making
copies help with those things well what
strategy did we talk about in this class
for dealing with mesh with message
omission in other words what what is the
strategy that we talked about for
reliable delivery of messages somebody
want to remind me
okay somebody just mentioned a couple of
replication strategies but we're just
talking about the message omission so
the problem of a message getting lost
somewhere between the sender and the
receiver how do you deal with that well
you deal with it by using a reliable
delivery protocol and a reliable
delivery delivery protocol involves
sending multiple copies of the message
until you find out that one got there
right how do you find out that it got
there because you get an acknowledgement
so sending a message many times until at
least one is acknowledged or until it
yeah until until it one so this is
called at least once delivery do we have
any way of guaranteeing that messages
will get there exactly once probably not
right so if you do this you might end up
getting duplicates that is something
that you have to be okay with if you
want the message to reliably get there
you have to be okay with the fact that
it might get there more than once so
that's one thing that we make copies up
we make copies of messages to deal with
omission faults so in addition to making
copies of messages to deal with omission
faults what are some other things that
we want to make copies of
make copies of time when we share vector
clocks interesting perspective that
wasn't exactly what I was thinking of I
was thinking of something a lot simpler
y'all I was just thinking of making
copies of data by replicating so one
reason why we do replication why did why
do we have more than one copy well if
one machine could crash then we probably
shouldn't have our data on just that one
machine so that's one reason why we
might want to have another replicas so
we can say dealing with machines
crashing via replication protocols
copying the same data in several
distinct physical locations ideally on
different machines and different
machines that would fail independently
right because you really don't want it
to be the case that all of your replicas
fail at once right so you you want to
make failures as independent as possible
so maybe have them not only that you
might want to have them in different
data centers right the trouble there is
the farther apart that they are the
harder it is to do replication so that's
one of those trade-offs that we've spent
the whole quarter talking about the
farther apart machines are the harder it
is to make sure that they agree of but
the farther apart they are the more
fault tolerance that we have we
typically choose a compromise right we
might choose to replicate over machines
that are in the same data center but
aren't on the same server rack something
like that we typically don't choose to
replicate our data to a data center on
Mars even though that would indeed
provide fault tolerance and clay in case
this planet is destroyed right because
replicating to and from Mars would be
very slow so you have to choose what
kind of faults are going to be tolerant
of okay so that's - I said that there
were two or three examples so the last
one I thought of was is in the context
of MapReduce so in MapReduce there's
this computation that's being
orchestrated by by one node who's
telling all of the worker node what what
to do right and if a worker fails then
they're never going to acknowledge to
the master that it was done right so the
master is going to have to decide what
to do and typically they're going to
have another node do the
work right so some work might get redone
some work might get duplicated so so map
produces way of dealing with some
computation getting lost is to just redo
it and this ends up being the
appropriate trade-off in many situations
so you could argue that it's inefficient
right because you're redoing work that
was already done and the alternative
would have been for this the the machine
that was doing this lost computation to
to very often save its work out to some
place where the work would be safe right
to the to the distributed file system um
but that would be slow if that machine
had to interrupt its work to
periodically save its work out to the
distributed file system so instead the
compromise that they choose is this
machines work gets lost if it gets
interrupted in the middle and instead we
just choose to recompute there are
always going to be in a typical
MapReduce computation there's always
going to be some redundant recomputation
like this well but not necessarily
always but the longer the computation
runs the more likely it is that that
some part of it will fail this way um so
those are three ways in which we make
copies so in this in the first scenario
we're dealing with the possibility of
message loss by making copies of
messages in the second one we're dealing
with the possibility of crash faults by
making copies of data and in the last
one we're again dealing with with crash
faults by redoing computation so these
perhaps these last two are somewhat
related but but these are these are
different ways in which we deal with
faults by making
peace that's what I had in mind when I
asked this question other questions
what else are you confused by
access all right hmm
so is there something specific that you
want me to discuss here
okay let's talk about um let's talk
about taxes for just a minute
maybe more than a minute so um so some
some some big-picture concepts in taxes
so taxes is a consensus protocol recall
that a consensus protocol is a protocol
by which participants can agree on a
value so each participant is allowed to
contribute something let's say they're
trying to agree on a bit and the idea is
that in the end they're all going to
agree so either these are all going to
be 0 or they're all going to be 1 notice
that they have to come up with that
agreement among themselves so there's no
external process that comes along that
says you all have to be 0 the whole
point of Paxos is that it's a
decentralized algorithm meaning that
there's no single point of failure which
means that there can't be any kind of
coordinator aside from these that's
going to come in and tell them what to
do now they can choose to elect a leader
among themselves and they can and do
choose to elect a leader among
themselves in the sense that it's in the
sense that there's often in like a
designated proposer right but there's no
external process that's going to make
that decision for them so how does that
work in the context of Paxos well in
Paxos um you're going to have some
number of what are called acceptors
typically an odd number so let's say we
have 3 acceptors let's say for now that
we just have 1 proposer so we'll call it
p1 here
here's what happens a proposer is going
to start not by proposing a value not by
proposing one of these things but but
simply by by giving what's called a
proposal number so proposal numbers have
to be unique and they have to be bigger
than any proposal number that that
particular proposal proposer has ever
used before let's say that this one
sends out the proposal number of five it
has to be sent to a majority of
acceptors which could be all of them
let's say it's all about so the first
kind of message that is involved in a
run of Paxos is a proposed message the
acceptors have to respond to the
proposed message with what's called a
promise a promise of five means I
promise to ignore messages with a
proposal number of less than five so if
somebody else comes along and they
propose four at this point or some other
proposer comes along and they proposed
for the acceptors will ignore it if
somebody else comes along and they
propose six then the proposers won't
ignore it they have to respond to it but
at this point they have promised to
ignore proposal any message with a
proposal number less than five at the
point when a majority of acceptors have
responded with such a promise which in
this diagram is right here so this mess
it doesn't really matter if it gets
there or not because we only have to
hear back from the majority at this
point
now this proposer is free to do the next
most important thing that they need to
do right is which is to actually propose
a value right so at this point
they can they can send out the value
that they want to have accepted by the
acceptors and that is called an accept
message they still have the proposal
number of five on there and then they
put the value which might be the string
to and then once again a majority of
acceptors which could be all of them
have to respond with what's called an
accepted message what are some ways in
which this could go wrong
well if another proposer happened to
come in here and talk to these acceptors
and get them to promise six before this
accept message landed on these acceptors
then if that happened
like if proposer two came in here and
and said okay maybe acceptors two and
three i proposed six and they responded
by promising six
in that case the acceptors would have to
ignore these accept messages coming in
here because they have a proposal number
of only five so this is a way in which
pecks us might not terminate right
because you could have this overlapping
of messages we call this dueling
proposers when there's proposers coming
in with messages getting a promise then
somebody else getting a promise but
nobody has ever get able to get there
except messages in in time for for them
to actually hear from a majority of
acceptors so the point hopefully this
doesn't happen right so one way to guard
against this happening is to try to only
have one proposer so the way in which
some consensus protocols operate is to
actually elect a leader to begin with
and to have that elected leader be the
only proposer so that's how graft works
for example it starts with a leader
election phase and then that elected
leader is the only proposer
in paxos you can implement it that way
the trouble is that leader election
itself involves getting consensus so
leader election also has the risk of not
terminating so you don't get around this
termination issue by doing leader
election because it itself could not
might not terminate if you do get into
this situation where you have these
dueling proposers one way around it is
to have different random timeouts on the
proposers before they decide to propose
again so then hopefully if you have
those different lengths of random
timeouts then the messages will not
continue to be interleaved in just the
wrong order so let's talk about what
would happen here if if if this if this
didn't happen
these acceptors actually do accept so at
this point right here when these two
acceptors have gotten this accept
message and sent back this message that
they've accepted this is the point at
which consensus has been reached in
other words if two acceptors accept a
particular proposal number and a
particular value from then on there's no
going back from there in paxos even
though not everybody knows yet that
consensus has been reached one way or
another that's the value that we're
going to end up having consensus on now
it could happen that now after that
proposer two comes along and tries to
propose six here and of course because
it's proposal number is six
these acceptors are still obligated to
respond to that message with a promise
but at that point because they've
already accepted something they have to
tell proposer to what it is that they
already accepted so they have to tell it
I accepted food and then when when
proposer 2 sends its own accept message
to propose a value it has to also
propose that same value of food so
proposer 2 is obligated by the Paxos
protocol to propose the same value that
it's just been told that has already
been accepted and that is how that that
is how this already accepted value ends
up spreading to the rest of the of the
participants that's practice in a
nutshell I recommend going back in
watching the lectures where we talked
about it in a lot more detail and talked
about some of the failure modes and so
on was that does that help I mean I
don't know I when you say you want more
information about Paxos that's my that's
my quick overview of it we could talk a
little bit about about the big picture
stuff so this this notion of this
consensus box right so
I mentioned that Texas might not
terminate right and we talked about the
properties that every consensus protocol
that we want consensus protocols to
satisfy but that no consensus property
or no consensus protocol can satisfy all
of so consensus protocols try to satisfy
these properties of validity which says
that the value that ends up being on
each of these lines is one of the ones
that you started with agreement which
says that they agree and termination
which says that you actually do get
something on each of the lines um but no
consensus protocol can actually satisfy
all three of those in an environment
where where messages are asynchronous
and where crash faults can occur so
Paxos this picks termination to be the
one that it doesn't guarantee some other
consensus protocols or some some other
protocols might choose to pick something
else not to not to do right so so a
protocol might actually choose to
satisfy termination and validity but not
agreement and why would it do that well
it might be the case that you're
actually okay with the participants
disagreeing so let's say it's a leader
election protocol and you're okay with
there being multiple leaders as long as
they're all leaders that were proposed
by somebody so that might be an a reason
why you might want to choose to have
termination and validity but not
agreement that's not the choice that
Paxos makes okay so somebody just asked
another question um what's an example of
a partially ordered set that's also a
totally ordered set okay um well every
totally ordered set is also a partially
ordered set so if we just take the
natural numbers right
so what what properties does something
have to obey in order to be a be a
partially ordered set so it or so okay
so first of all when we talk about a
partially ordered set we're talking
about a set and it's in this case we're
talking about this set of natural
numbers and we're talking about a binary
relation on the elements of that set so
if we talk about this order let's say
it's the the less than or equal to
ordering on the natural numbers so
there's our set
there's our relation so let's talk about
the properties of that relation is it
reflexive in other words is it the case
that for all elements of this set does
the relation relate each of them to each
other is to less than or equal to two is
3 less than or equal to 3 is 5 million
less than or equal to 5 million yes so
that one checks out is it anti-symmetric
in other words what does anti symmetry
say it says that for all a and B if a is
less than or equal to B & B is less than
or equal to a then then a equals B well
yeah that one checks out to write these
two premises of this are not going to be
true unless we're actually talking about
the same number right so so that one
checks out
the last one is transitive transitivity
says that if you have a B and C a is
less than B and B is less than C then a
is less
or equal to see and is that one true for
natural numbers for this relation yeah
okay so meets all the criteria for being
a partially ordered set it so happens
that it's also a totally ordered set
which means that every two elements in
here are going to have an order
according to this so if we had been
talking about a partially ordered set
that was not a totally ordered set for
example set containment so for example
the subsets of a of a set so we know
that the empty set is smaller than the
set containing a and we know that the
set containing a is smaller than the set
containing a and B and we know that the
empty set is smaller than the set
containing B and the set containing B is
smaller than the set containing a and B
but these two don't have a relationship
write that like that right we can't say
that the set containing a is smaller
than the set containing B we can't say
the set containing B is smaller than the
set containing a there's not a
relationship there and so this is an
example of a partial order that's not a
total order because there are some pairs
of elements in here that don't have a
relationship
unlike the natural numbers ordered by
this relation which is which when we
draw out the lattice relating elements
to each other we just get a straight
line because there is in fact
relationship between every two elements
so these properties that make something
a partial order are also going to be
true of every total order it's just that
total orders have this additional
property that every two elements are
related whereas a partial order it's not
guaranteed that every two elements are
related by the order that's the
difference
so how does this come up for us well
it's these kinds of partial orders that
are the most interesting right the ones
where not every two elements are related
in other words the partial orders that
are not total orders because these are
the ones where we actually have an
interesting problem to solve like if one
replica thinks that it's state is the
set containing a and another replica
thinks that it state is the set
containing B if there was an order you
know if there was a total order right
then then we might have a way to
actually resolve it more meaningfully
right but just if we just look at the
two of them and try to compare them like
we can't really say well this one is
better than the other right so the
answer ends up being like we said we can
choose to take the least upper bound if
there's a meaningful least upper bound
or we can just kick both of the both of
these to the user and ask the user to
figure it out asking the application to
figure it out okay one person is often
asking if I can talk about upper bounds
and least upper bounds and join semi
lattices again alright so let's talk
about that just briefly so in a partial
order
that's not also a total order an
interesting partial order one like this
one it's sometimes going to be the case
that every two elements have a least
upper bound and sometimes it's not going
to be the case so here's an example of a
partial order where not every two
elements have a least upper bound it's
the example that we talked about before
in class but it but I think it's a
useful one so I'll talk about it again
so
this is a picture of a boolean register
that could be either empty or it could
be true or it could be false right so
this is an example it's a partial order
right because we're saying that empty is
less than true in the partial order so
if we want we can write it like this
empty is also less than false but
there's not a relationship between true
and false right so we can also say empty
is less than or equal to itself and true
is less than or equal to itself and
false is less than or equal to itself so
it's reflexive right reflexivity checks
out it's also anti symmetric and
transitive vacuously but but it's not
it's not the case that every two
elements have a have a least upper bound
because we can't look at these two and
find and we can't look at a true and
false and say okay here's something
that's at least as big as both because
there isn't anything in there that is so
this corresponds to a scenario in
distributed systems where if you have
one replica that thinks that the state
of something is true and you have
another replica that thinks that the
state of something is false you can't
unless you have something like like
vector clocks that tell you that that
one of those is more recent than the
other then you can't really you can't
really resolve that conflict in a way
that that makes sense right so this
would be a scenario where you you might
need to tell the user
well one replica thinks the answer is
true and the other one thinks the answer
is false you figure it out um on the
other hand if you did have a meaningful
uh upper-bound so going back to our
previous example where we have sets so
an upper bound of a and B in this
partial order is of the set containing a
in the set containing B is the set
containing both a and B so if you have a
set containing if one replica thinks
that the that the state is the set
containing a and another one thinks that
the state is the set containing B then
those replicas have a way of
meaningfully converging on the same
state and that could either be done by
the client or it could be done by the
system itself so the informal claim that
I made in class is that if you can
guarantee that the states that your
replicas can take on our elements of a
join semi lattice and a join semi
lattice is just a partial order where
every two elements are guaranteed to
have what's called a least upper bound
if you can if the out there the the the
states that your replicas can take on
our elements of a joint semi lattice
then we have a natural way of resolving
conflicts without having to run a
consensus protocol that was my informal
claim um so what's the difference
between an upper bound and a least upper
bound well maybe this was part of a
bigger system right where where you
could also have a set containing a b and
c so the set containing a b and c is
also an upper bound of the set
containing a and the set containing B in
the sense that it's bigger than both so
the upper bound of two elements an upper
bound of two elements in a partially
ordered set is any element in this set
that's at least as big as both so this
element is at least as big as both of
those elements and so is this one but
this one is the least upper bound this
one is more interesting because it's
the smallest of all of the upper bounds
of these two elements and the least
upper bound is the one that's
interesting to us because we want to
find a way to resolve the conflict
between these two in in the in kind of
the most meaningful way possible right
so it doesn't necessarily mean very much
if we've resolved every conflict where
these sets differ by saying I'll just
throw everything into this set right
because then every replica would end up
being ABC instead we want to resolve the
conflict in the way that's closest to
what these what these individuals said
so that's why the notion of least upper
bound is useful to us
about 15 minutes left
fun I'm kind of being forced to talk
about all these concepts that are that
without notes right like normally
normally I prepare for lecture right and
I have a plan about what I'm going to
talk about and I practice it and I and I
have no my own notes which are typically
chicken scratches but no this is great
I'm actually having being forced to talk
about these concepts without any
preparation it's good for me all right
so in the few minutes that we have
remaining I have some stuff that I want
to talk about but I still want to I
still want to know if you have more
questions for me they don't necessarily
have to be questions about the course I
want to actually address one thing that
that came up earlier in the class that I
feel a little bit bad about so on I
think on the start of course survey
somebody asked me what is it like being
a woman in CS and I kind of flippantly
answered that by saying well you have to
deal with lots people asking you what
it's like to be a woman in CS uh-huh so
of course that's not a complete answer
and I didn't mean to make it sound like
it was but there's a lot of reading
material that I can recommend on that
topic if you want to know so please come
talk to me about that if you're
interested or you can just talk to me
about my personal experiences that's
fine too um the other thing I want to
talk about so I want to talk a little
bit about contextualizing this class in
kind of the bigger picture of the world
um so we've been talking a lot of play
going back to the very beginning of this
class what did we say a distributed
system was well we said that it
distribute its that one of the
characteristics of a distributed system
was constant partial failure right
we said that a distributed system was
running on many nodes connected by a
network and characterized by this at
this constant partial failure and the
what we called the cloud computing
philosophy was the philosophy that we
would attempt to keep running
despite this partial failure so instead
of stopping when we detected a failure
throwing everything out and starting all
over instead we would attempt to keep
going in the face of this constant
partial failure and the argument is that
that's the only practical approach when
you're in a system of many many
thousands or even hundreds of thousands
of machines where something is
guaranteed to always be failing so
there's no practical way to just start
over when there's a failure because you
would be always starting over so instead
you have to learn to tolerate those
failures and so we've spent a lot of the
class talking about techniques for
tolerating failures
and we've talked about I mentioned
several techniques a minute ago for for
fault tolerance via making copies
whether it's making copies of messages
to ensure reliable delivery of messages
making copies of data to guard against
machines crashing or redoing an entire
computation to make a copy of the
computation essentially in order to be
tolerant of of a computation getting
lost all of these are ways to deal with
failures so I think an important kind of
point to keep in mind here is
distributed systems are good designs for
distributed systems are designed to
tolerate failure
but that toleration of failure also
makes distributed systems incredibly
hard to debug because distributed
systems hide their own failures by
design
and what I mean by that is when we
implement these algorithms that are
designed to be tolerant of failure like
let's say it's Paxos so Paxos will keep
working if you have let's say three
acceptors and one acceptor fails it can
continue to work in that situation
because you only have to hear back from
a majority of acceptors in order for
paksas to keep running and so the other
participants in the system they might
not even know that that acceptor failed
they might not know they might not they
have no reason to care so how would you
how would you find out right that a
failure occurred if your system is
designed in a way to hide its own
failures and this is one of the things
that makes debugging distributed systems
so difficult so if the system is
designed to keep running despite
failures so who are these failures being
hidden from first of all well certainly
the failures have to be hidden from
those outside the system right if you're
implementing key value store and
replicas can fail then clients of that
key value store are not supposed to be
able to tell that replicas failed right
at least your system it is supposed to
be able to withstand a certain amount of
failure and there's an ideally a
client's of the system won't notice that
there was a failure of course this can't
be perfect right if all of the replicas
fail then then certainly clients are
going to notice but there's some degree
of failure that the system is supposed
to be designed to withstand so those
outside the system are not supposed to
be able to observe these failures
furthermore those inside the system who
don't know it's broken might not be able
to observe the failures so um so in
Paxos for instance if you have if you
have one
one proposer who let's say keeps on
sending let's say I don't know so let's
say we have this um this proposer over
here whose a kind of doom to always be
behind a proposer one and so let's say
let like it just keeps on sending
proposals that always get ignored
because they keep on having just a
little bit too low of a proposal number
and so proposer one always wins and so
messages are happening here and then
just being summarily ignored by the by
the acceptors meanwhile proposer one is
always getting its messages acknowledged
and then is getting to getting to
actually um suggests a value to be
accepted and then having it accepted so
these messages are over here or always
being ignored proposer one has no idea
that this is happening over here right
proposer one may not know that that
proposer two was trying to propose
something and proposer one has no
concept of this being unfair if you will
right so not only do those outside this
system right let's say let's say that
this is some kind of replicated data
store which is using Paxos and clients
of this system aren't aren't able to
observe the failure um
neither is proposer one like even from
within this system you might not be able
to tell that there's the that there's
something broken here in fact you could
argue the là-bas isn't broken this is
exactly how it's supposed to work and
then you could argue that the
there's an analogy to society here right
so societies arguably distributed system
right or society is a distributed system
and much like the systems that we've
discussed in our class it's
characterized by this constant partial
failure and it's very tolerant of
failure in the sense that things can
soar to keep working at least to an
external observer
even though parts of the system are
horribly broken right and not only that
but even those within the system might
not be able to observe that other parts
of it are broken worse yet it some
participants might know that it's broken
but have no intention of fixing it
because it's serving their needs right
so what do we do about this right if the
system is broken and it's designed to
hide its own failures how can you
possibly go about fixing it well so one
interesting technique that's that's used
for debugging that's kind of gotten a
lot of press in the last few years is
something called chaos engineering so
chaos engineering which got a lot of
press for for its use at Netflix
although they're not the only people who
use it
chaos engineering is causing failures in
a live system on purpose
to see what bugs are revealed so for
example causing a replica to fail in a
in a distributed replicated data store
or or maybe causing an acceptor to fail
in a paxos cluster something like that
so this idea of causing failures on
purpose and a live system in a
production system this is the system
that's actually streaming your your
Netflix movies to see what bugs are
revealed this is a this is a technique
to try to reveal those failures that
that get hidden normally um so so this
is dangerous right it's a little bit
risky to do because you could you know
if you if you do if you have a bug right
you could end up breaking something in
in production and this the the whole
point of this chaos engineering is that
it that it has to be done in production
right because the production system
might have characteristics that whatever
testing environment that you have
doesn't have and and so actually
actually causing failures in the
production system in order to reveal
bugs is is risky to do but but a very
effective way to find bugs so if I if I
can make a perhaps strained analogy but
but one that I think is worth making to
society well causing failures in a
system on purpose to see what bugs are
revealed is kind of what is being done
when people carry out civil disobedience
so if you if you cause a failure that
you hope is relatively benign right like
in chaos engineering but it but it
reveals some other failure that then
then you should fix then then maybe it
was worth causing that failure so in
that in the sense in in by the same go
that that same analogy I said if civil
disobedience against police brutality
for example reveals further police
brutality and so I think this is
something that the that is very much
intentional on the part of protesters
right and so it's dangerous it's a
dangerous technique because by putting
yourself your body out there on the line
to try to reveal a way in which the
system is broken you're it's very
dangerous you're you're opening yourself
up to to to physical danger to yourself
but you're doing so in order to reveal a
way in which the
system is broken and I think this is
analogous to chaos engineering although
it much more dangerous and this is not
necessarily the only reason to carry out
civil disobedience but it's a way to
increase everyone's awareness of the way
in which the system is broken so one
thing that you can do is you leave this
classes think about the the systems that
you participate in think about the ways
in which those systems are hiding their
failures from you by design and think
about the way in which you can increase
your awareness of the ways in which
those systems fail
that's all I have to say thank you so
much to all of you for being great
participants in this course this quarter
thanks to all of you on twitch - for
tuning in and and thanks to everybody
who left great comments on youtube it's
meant a lot to me to have this kind of
participation from people all around the
world it's not it's not lost on me that
the the people who are watching on
twitch and the people who are commenting
on YouTube a lot of them are not are not
in the US and it's it's been very
special to me to be able to speak to
people around the world and the fact
that you're willing to participate in
this class which might not be in at
times and that's at all convenient for
you so thank you thanks to all of you
thanks to everybody who's taking the
class please stay in touch come talk to
me especially if you're graduating I
would love to know what happens to you
next and take care other than that I'll
be on slack to help answer questions as
you're studying for the final exam and
best wishes good luck with everything
take care